[Musique]
Lancelot Guyot s'est lancé dans une
expérience inédite au château des jeux
de Saint-Brisson l'objectif de Lancelot
et de préserver et de faire vivre des
édifices prestigieux grâce au tourisme
aux événements et à l'innovation car il
est convaincu que les châteaux sont un
atout majeur de transmission et ma
conseiller des clés
les clés du château
bienvenue au Château des jeux de
Saint-Brisson un château qui date du de
c'est dans le temps là 12e siècle Kamini
merci Lancelot merci beaucoup c'est un
emplacement parfait pour se faire
chanter une sérénade comme à l'époque
[Musique]
tu descends pourquoi faire Monseigneur
c'est votre destiné non seulement c'est
votre destinée
là je t'emmène dans les 12 du château
donc on est en contrebas mais alors toi
quand tu arrives ici le château est dans
quel état le Shadow est plutôt dans un
bon état le parc est un peu en friche
l'intérieur du château voilà on a fait
pas mal de travail pour recréer des
atmosphères des ambiances faire en sorte
que en fait les gens puissent se
projeter aussi un peu dans une époque tu
vois imaginez comment il vivait
autrefois et par contre ça ça s'appelle
un Couillard un Couillard voilà
explicite avait une histoire de Corones
je vais essayer un peu au tir à l'arc là
parce que tu t'appelles quand même
Lancelot ouais j'avais un prénom un
prénom prédestiné je soupçonne d'avoir
1500 ans c'est important pour nous que
en fait même les adultes en fait
s'amusent en visitant un château et de
toute façon en fait un lieu de vie tu
vois je déteste le fait que les châteaux
soient considérés comme des musées en
fait j'ai envie que les gens vivent une
expérience voient les machines de guerre
qui visitent le château et qu'en fait il
soit acteur aussi de leur visite tu
modernise un peu c'est cet univers cet
univers des visites de château avec
carrément des des festivals de musique
festival électro ouais on organise des
festivals à Saint-Brisson un petit
festival du coup qui a une jauge plutôt
à 1000 personnes et c'est pas forcément
des gens qui prendrai le temps d'aller
visiter les châteaux justement tu
ramènes un nouveau public exactement
ouais et ça c'est vraiment au cœur moi
de ce que j'aime faire c'est d'arriver à
garder un lieu qui soit le plus
authentique possible mais d'arriver à
faire venir justement ce public qui n'a
pas l'habitude de visiter le château
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là on est au château de Saint-Brisson
mais tu en as d'autres ouais exactement
on en gère 4 en tout comment tu fais
pour répartir ton temps de travail
là-dessus clairement je bosse beaucoup
mais après c'est de la passion et c'est
une vraie osmose avec les équipes
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes pour
certains des gens qui venaient en plus
de la région qui avait un attachement
avec le lieu et c'est une victoire
j'ai vaincu lorsque le Grand Chevalier
on va à l'intérieur du château
et les gars vous faites quoi là elle est
mission elle dure 4 minutes on a pas le
temps c'est un vieux jeu et en fait le
principe c'est d'essayer d'avancer du
coup ensemble et là ils sont sur les
skis mais ils sont bien synchronisés à
la beau travail d'équipe et souvent les
gens se cassent la gueule
je vais te montrer une pièce étonnante
cabinet de curiosité du marquis ça
correspond vraiment en fait à des pièces
qu'il y avait dans les châteaux ou en
général les propriétaires et
collectionner des choses atypiques au
moment de la Toussain on fait des
visites hantée des visites
[Musique]
vous allez vous faire mal au dos si vous
restez trop longtemps j'ai déjà mal au
dos j'ai déjà mal au dos
donc là c'est bon salle à manger salle à
manger le salon à côté ça c'est du
incroyable qui s'offre à toi quoi au
plafond de toutes les familles
différents qui correspond en fait à
toutes les familles successives qui ont
habité ici du en gros milieu du 12e
siècle jusqu'en 1987 je crois quand la
dernière marquise de Saint-Brisson est
morte et la légué le château à la
commune le monsieur qu'on voit là c'est
Lui qui a créé l'Académie française
c'est le chancelier donc c'était le
propriétaire de Saint-Brisson qui a créé
donc l'Académie française alors j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle à Monsieur c'est qui
après ils ont créé la Star Academy je
suis désolé je suis désolé je vois dans
votre regard que le côté c'est quand
même un peu hanté
[Rires]
[Musique]